politics is dangerous there's no safe
harbor police could become Gestapo
taxation could become confiscation but
we need police and we need taxation
there is no safety in politics life is
lived on a slippery slope get over
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special I am overjoyed to
welcome to the set George will who
requires no introduction his brand new
book is the conservative Sensibility mr.
will thank so much for stopping by the
review so how did you become George well
somebody knows your name obviously
you're probably the most prominent
conservative thinker of the last 30 to
40 years so how did you become George
well how did you get to where you are
grew up in central Illinois the son of a
college professor at the University of
Illinois went to Trinity College as an
undergraduate went to Oxford when I left
Oxford I applied to a distinguished law
school and to Princeton and philosophy I
couldn't decide whether to be a lawyer
or a professor of political philosophy I
went to Princeton because it was midway
between two national league cities
baseball being the center of my life at
all times taught for a few years
everett dirksen died a Republican
senator who led the Republicans they
shuffled the Republican leadership a
Colorado senator of whom I'd never heard
got elected third ranking Republicans
said I want a higher rep of public and
academic to write for me there were no
Republican academics except me and I was
in Canada at the University of Toronto
we got together I went to worked on the
Senate staff for three years then I
called Bill Buckley for whom I've
written a few pieces and said you need a
Washington editor of a National Review
there hadn't been one bill essentially
said you're right I do and you're it
that was Bill had this habit of sort of
collecting young people who took a shine
to at about that time Spiro Agnew for
your audience he was a vice president
United States under Richard Nixon was
running around the country saying
they're too few conservative columnist
so the Washington Post said we'll
syndicate will as someone who will
defend Richard Nixon so I became a
columnist in January 1973 just as Judge
Sirica was imposing the sentences that
caused the Watergate cover-up to unravel
and I instantly decided Nixon was guilty
and it's probably going to leave and
probably should leave so that marketing
plan for my column didn't work out but
anyway
that's how I got to become a columnist
and
in a second I wanna ask you how you
decide on the topics of what you write
because you are famously not writing
very much about Donald Trump who's
apparently the center and lodestar of
all political talk these days when asked
about that in just one second first if
you can trust certain elements in
Silicon Valley to treat conservatives
fairly why would you trust them to
handle your privacy and personal online
data and why would you trust Silicon
Valley to do all of that I mean the fact
is that you got big companies like
Twitter that are overtly attempting to
ban ads that they don't like on the
basis of political viewpoints and then
they're working hand go up Elizabeth
Warren well that's why I recommend using
expressive VPN every single time you go
online big tech companies can use your
IP address to match your internet
activity to your identity or location
when I use Express VPN search engines
and media sites they can't see my IP
address at all my identity is masked and
anonymous expressvpn has the added
benefit of encrypting 100% of your data
to keep you safe from people you don't
want to have that data after all it's
your data expressvpn software takes just
a minute to set up on your computer or
phone you tap one button you are now
protected so if you're like me you
believe your internet data belongs to
you and now two giant tech companies who
probably don't like you very much
expressvpn is indeed the answer plus it
protects you against hackers which is a
big thing if you ever had your data
stolen it's not a lot of fun protect
your online activity today with the VPN
I trust to keep my data safe because it
expressvpn calm slash Ben to claim an
exclusive offer for my fans
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with the one-year
package visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
okay so let's talk about how you decide
what to write about so everybody is
obsessed with President Trump every
column is on President Trump every
spoken word it seems is about President
Trump doesn't matter where you are you
go to the hairdresser's and everybody's
talking about President Trump you don't
write about President Trump all that
much so how do you decide what you do
right well I once asked Bill Buckley
when I first started this the question
that I now know is the most common
question asked of a columnist how do you
come up with things to write about and
bill said the world irritates me three
times a week I would just modify that to
say the world
prompts my curiosity amuses me annoys
may something three times a week I have
in my pocket at all times my wallet a
little card with topics I want to get to
next I write a lot about court cases
Supreme Court cases and others I write
about foreign policy I've recently been
in Korea Taiwan and Hong
the world is so interesting and the 45th
president is so boring exquisitely
boring he has one pedal on the organ
that's all he works there are
journalists who write about him twice we
columnist and you scream in your head
tell me something I don't already know
they say twice a week he's a bore he's
allowed his uninformed etc know that
tell me something interesting now well
we'll get to trump talk a little bit
later because frankly I agree with you
and I think that you know all of the
talk about President Trump tends to
revolve around one of two notes either
he's the greatest person who has ever
lived in the universe or he is the worst
person ever to have lived in the
universe and none of it seems to be
reflective of reality but we'll get to
that in a little bit I want to ask you a
lot about your book because your book
really is a primer for people who don't
understand conservatism or don't know
much about conservatism on what
conservatism should be so it's called
first of all the conservative
sensibility for folks who haven't read
it it is a terrific book but why did you
call it the conservative sensibility as
opposed to say the conservative agenda
the the sort of conservative first
conservative principles you know there's
this great divide in in sort of
conservative thinking over whether a
conservatism is in fact a sensibility
and an outlook on the world or whether
it is a series of principles for which
you are supposed to stand or is it both
so why the Sensibility well the title
the conservative mind was taken by
Russell Kirk about 60 years ago by
sensibility I mean more than an attitude
but less than an agenda I didn't want to
give 10 legislative measures to make
America great again or anything else I
think a conservative sensibility is sort
of a Michael Oakshott great political
philosopher approach which is that
there's a way of responding to the given
of life the flux the uncertainty the
exhilarating openness of the future it
has been well said I think by Virginia
press well that the story of the Bible
reduced to one sentences God created men
and women on lost control of events the
conservative sensibility says terrific
we don't we want uncontrolled events we
want the exhilaration of an open future
in an open society to make the future
open
you either welcome that in which case
you're a good American conservative or
you want to bring events to heal you
want to organize things plan them direct
them from above in which case you're
good progressive and which I've just
framed I think the American political
argument for the last at least 120 years
and in the book you boiled that down to
a couple of different ways of thinking
the Madisonian way of thinking the
Wilsonian way of thinking and I was
wondering if you could elucidate
explicate on that a little bit what
exactly do you mean by that distinction
James Madison of the great Princeton
class of 1771 gave us three thoughts
basically he didn't give him to us but
he incorporated them natural rights
rights precede government the first a
great word in the Declaration of
Independence is secure all men are
created equal endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights and
governments are instituted to secure
those rights as Randy Barnett the great
constitutional lawyer says first comes
rights then comes government that
inherently
limits the role of government to being
strong enough to protect our rights and
not so strong to threaten our rights
second that presupposes there is a fixed
human nature that we are not just
creatures that acquire whatever culture
we're surrounded by once you deny that
as the progressive thinkers at the
beginning of the 20th century did once
you deny a settled human nature that man
is plastic to the touch of culture you
emancipate government for the most
dangerous of its 20th century projects
to create new Soviet man new German man
to modify human beings
that's when government really becomes at
its most sinister third the medicine Ian
project says because of the first two
fixed human nature human rights
essential to the flourishing of
creatures like us we need a government
that is checked and balanced a
separation of powers so that it will be
effective
but slow and modified because it is the
nature of human beings to be passionate
creatures and passions are problems and
therefore we want majority rule but
majority opinion should be filtered and
refined and reflected through
institutions and slowed-down long comes
Woodrow Wilson from the great Princeton
class of 1879 and says that was fine
long ago but it's an anachronism when
there were 4 million Americans 80% of
them living within 20 miles of Atlantic
Tidewater when we were a simple rural
country that was fine but now we are a
great country united by steel rails and
copper wires we need a strong organizing
government we need to bring expertise to
bear on the affairs of the common people
we need to concentrate more power in
Washington more Washington power in the
executive branch more executive branch
power and the president and in such
administrative agencies as he creates
therefore we should we should
marginalize Congress and we should
understand that rights are granted by
the government for our own good
and the government will tell us what
rights we ought to have and it will be
advised in this by experts the great
text of progressivism is Herbert
Crowley's the promise of American life
published in 1909 never out of print
since then an amazing text Louis
Brandeis gave a copy to Teddy Roosevelt
who took it on a safari he went off to
assassinate large animals which he
thought was great fun and he read it
hath their hand we've been suffering
from it ever since but Crowley says that
Americans by and large are unregenerate
citizens and he had a plan to regenerate
us through government so when it comes
to the Madisonian vision it seems like
there's a fair bit of conflict inside
the conservative movement even about
what the Madisonian vision encompasses
let's start with a few of those premises
let's start with the the natural rights
premise so there's an argument that's
now made inside the conservative
movement that we are a movement that is
too much focused on rights
and not enough focused on duties and
this has led to a small government
conservatism that is unsustainable for
the future it's an argument made by some
people for example Tucker Carlson has
made this sort of argument that
basically we are so focused on
individual rights that we've forgotten
that we have to take care of each other
and you need government to come in and
help take care of us in that way for
that argument from frankly george w bush
and in sort of his compassionate
conservative days so what do you make of
that argument where how do we define
what indeed is a natural right well we
define them I think ultimately it will
rule utilitarians we look through
history we look through contemporary
experience and we say what constitutes
human flourishing people argue about
this what rights are essential to that
we argue about that if you don't like
arguing you pick the wrong country
because Americans argue we're condemned
to that some of us like that the kind of
conservatism you're talking about some
of them call themselves national
conservatives and all the rest there is
a rebellion against individualism now
they begin with the obvious point which
I make much of in my book of course
human beings are all situated but that
does not mean that they are mere
creatures of their culture the revolt
against individualism is draw driven
nowadays in no small measure by
religious conservatives and particularly
Catholic conservatives who I think are
understandably distraught that their
congregations are getting smaller and
that Christianity's hold on the American
public has weakened and their solution
is the weaker it gets the stronger it
ought to be through politics and I think
that's a non-sequitur and it's
unrealistic I mean I tend to agree I've
always made the argument you know
frequently and strongly that we do need
more and stronger religious communities
to back these sort of preservation of
Rights but that doesn't mean that it can
be done from top down by the government
because that would be precisely the
opposite of the sort of freedom of
religion that you need to flourish in
order to preserve rights that if writes
rely on our ability to take care of
they're in a dutiful way and rely on a
community you don't want the government
doing that job it actually tends to
quash religious freedom over time I
guess the the kind of follow-up
questions in the definition of natural
rights is you could easily see that
perverted by the wide definition of
natural rights what I mean by that is
that if we don't define natural rights
either specifically or to a certain
point narrowly you could see a
government that is designed to secure
those rights securing rights that may
not in fact be rights and using the
power of government to do so absolutely
Madison and others although Madison
really wrote the Bill of Rights more
than anyone else when the founders
framers that cause there's less
Philadelphia they didn't think they
needed a Bill of Rights
turns out they needed it to get the
Constitution ratified so they promptly
said fine ratify it will amend it with a
Bill of Rights one of the reasons the
framers were opposed to that they said
the structure of the Constitution is
itself a bill of rights it is sufficient
to defend freedom second once you start
enumerated rights where do you stop what
if you leave some out
hence the ninth amendment saying the
fact that we've enumerated some rights
does not disparage or denigrate the
possibility of unenumerated rights but
the government should also protect now
people say but how do you decide isn't
this dangerous the answer is yes
politics is dangerous there's no safe
harbor police could become Gestapo
taxation could become confiscation but
we need police and we need taxation
there is no safety in politics life is
lived on a slippery slope get over it so
I want to ask you in a second about
those checks and balances about the
structural Constitution but first I love
my helix sleep mattress why when I'm on
the road I can't sleep I can't sleep cuz
it's just a generic mattress I want a
mattress that is made for me well good
news that's what helix sleep does hulex
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete they match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or firm bed with helix
no more confusion no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by GQ and Wired magazine just
go to helix sleep calm /ban take their
two minutes sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split the
mattress down
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free so what
exactly are you waiting for they will
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will I love my helix
sleep mattress it's so good I got one
for my sister for her wedding it is just
that good a mattress helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
just for our listeners get up to 125
bucks off at helix sleep comm slash Ben
that's helix sleep coms last Ben for up
to 125 dollars off your mattress order
helix sleep comm slash Ben okay so let's
talk about these structural
constitutions so one of the points in
your book where I found myself a little
bit taken aback actually was your
argument for the strength of the
judiciary so I've always been an
advocate of the position that judiciary
is at the very least the third most
powerful branch of the government that
judicial review under Marbury vs.
Madison is at best a stretch assumed by
the Supreme Court I sort of agree with
the Alexander Bickel argument that this
is an assumption of power by the Supreme
Court that was not actually justified by
these structural checks and balances
you're allowed pretty heavily on the
judiciary to defend rights and I tend to
think having watched the progression of
the judiciary over the last 50 years
that that's an exceedingly dangerous
position and actually avoid some of the
sort of conflicts that you've been
talking about the embrace of the chaotic
nature of back-and-forth democracy
having a judiciary that simply says
there's a right cramming it down
we're done here why do you rely so
heavily on the judiciary conservatives
for many years and I among them Bob Bork
was a close personal friend believe that
partly prompted by the excesses of the
war on court that in fact the judiciary
should defer more judicial restraint
meant judicial deference to the elected
branches and I believe that until I quit
believing it it's the biggest change of
my life and it's now is a very
interesting it most interesting
political arguments in the United States
are not between conservatives and
progressives they're among conservatives
right now one of which is those of us
among conservatives who now argue for
what's called judicial engagement Clark
Neely with the Cato Institute is a
particularly brutal book of that title
let me go back to central Illinois where
I grew up
according to local Laura was in the
Champaign County Courthouse that Abraham
Lincoln heard about the passage of the
kansas-nebraska act of 1854 by another
Illinois and Steven a Douglas Douglas
said we're going to solve the problem of
whether to expand slavery into the
territories by popular sovereignty and
the territories voted up vote it down
it's a matter of indifference because
the important thing about America is
majority rule
Lincoln's ascent to greatness to the
greatest career in the history of world
politics in my judgment began with his
recoil against the kansas-nebraska act
where he said America is not about
majority rules about liberty we're for
majority rule whenever and to the extent
that it is as it usually is a bulwark of
Liberty but it is not always there for I
mean the Bill of Rights is a tissue of
prohibitions if the majority wants to
abridge free speech or to establish
religion or to abridge the right to
petition for too bad majorities can't
have it majorities can't do lots of
things that's the question I wrote my
doctoral dissertations title was beyond
the reach of majorities it was in the
second flag salute cased West Virginia v
Barnett Justice Robert Jackson said the
very purpose of a Bill of Rights was to
place certain things beyond the reach of
majorities above the vicissitudes of
politics I think judicial deference
often is dereliction of the judicial
duty to make sure that what majoritarian
institutions do be at a City Council be
at a state legislature that says you
have to salute a flag even if you're a
Jehovah's Witness and they offends your
deepest beliefs that courts ought to be
more actively engaged than they have
been particularly in defending economic
rights in laying what the majoritarian
institutions do next
the Constitution and next to the
Constitution as construed in the bright
light cast by the Declaration of
Independence that's the second side of
this Timothy Sandefur tremendous young
lawyer and scholar written a book called
the conscience of the Constitution which
I recommend all your viewers and he says
first comes the constant the Declaration
of then comes the Constitution and
Lincoln's famous formulation the
Declaration of Independence is the apple
of gold that is framed by the frame of
silver that is the Constitution
we are not about majority rule we are
about Liberty I agree with the central
premise but I do wonder again kind of
linking the two questions that I've
asked already
if you broadly construed and then you
broadly construe the ability of courts
to implement those rights don't you end
up with almost a lull Sounion
perspective on government just from the
judiciary not the executive it becomes
dangerous but again go back to what I
said earlier there is no safe spot in
politics any anything we do is going to
on this life lived on the slippery slope
yes you could have the irrigation of
essentially democratic decisions by
legislatures minting new Rights I mean
by a judicial people minting new rights
that reflect their policy preferences
that is a danger and nationalizing
perceptions of rights meaning that the
founders were also very much concerned
with the Montesquieu point that localism
mattered when it came to definition of
particular rights and so defining sort
of levels of rights there were obviously
rights to be protected by the federal
government but the federal government is
really the Bill of Rights at bridges the
powers of the federal government it's
really not meant to enable the federal
government to cram things down state so
much amendment to stop Congress from
legislature against the First Amendment
not to give the federal government power
to encroach on the rights of states
person correct but I think conservatives
should welcome should embrace in fact
the incorporation of the bill of rights
by the 14th amendment that that now the
Bill of Rights now applies to the states
I think we should go back and relitigate
the slaughterhouse cases of 1873
the court gave a ridiculously truncated
understanding of the privileges or
immunities of an American citizen I
think the purpose of the 14th amendment
was to define rights of national
citizenship that superseded those of the
states I think it is fair to say that
the Civil War amendments were in a way
completing the American Founding now
about localism Madison called
first the Annapolis convention leading
to the Philadelphia Convention in order
to strengthen the central government
because Madison was appalled by the
results of localism during what the
historians rightly called a critical
period of American history
the period under the Articles of
Confederation what were local people
doing they were responding to local
majorities they were canceling debts
they were running roughshod over due
process remember Madison's great
revolution and democratic theory was not
friendly to localism it was this before
Madison the very few people who had
thought democracy was possible at all
said it had to be in a small face to
face society Pericles Athens Rousseau's
Geneva a place you could walk across in
a day because they said the enemy of
freedom is and democracy is factionists
so you want to have a small homogeneous
polity without factions medicine said
that is exactly wrong what we need is to
understand this the affections are sown
and the nature of man he said I'm gonna
have factions therefore we need a saving
multiplicity of factions he had a
catechism what is the worst outcome of
politics tyranny - what form of tyranny
our democracies pray tyranny of the
majority solution don't have majorities
gonna have majorities but they're going
to be unstable majorities shifting
coalition's of factions therefore we
need an extensive Republic so that you
have government's first task being
medicine said in 10 and 51 the
protection of the different and unequal
capacities of acquiring property because
that will produce different factions and
a saving multiplicity of factions will
produce freedom so remember the
Constitution was written by people from
Madison to Alexander Hamilton they
immediately after the Constitution
became enemies and half rivals but there
they understood the first thing was to
pull government up from localism so that
we could have an effective national
government but the federalization of
politics the the removal of rights from
the state level to the enforcement
mechanism of the federal government well
obviously everyone agrees that with
regards to slavery and with regard to
Jim Crow that's a very good thing and
very positive for the country it does
result in a deep-seated rage that I
think a lot of people are feeling in the
country right now which is the loss of
local control a belief that you're now
your life is now being controlled either
by judges on the one hand or by
regulators in the executive branch on
the other and by legislators who
basically kick their task over to both
the regulators and the judges I recall
during the campaign finance reform
debates george w bush signing into law
campaign finance reform and suggesting
that he thought it was unconstitutional
but that it was the job of the supreme
court to weigh in on that yeah that's
interesting because before the Iowa
caucuses in 2002 the early 2000 I was he
was on our program on ABC and I asked
him I told him before the show I'm gonna
ask you about mccain-feingold
and I said is this unconstitutional the
government with campaign finance laws
which I think are all unconstitutional
it's the government stipulating the
quantity content and timing of political
speech about government I said is that
unconstitutional yes he said would you
veto it if it came to you he said yes of
course he signed it in a secret doing
just what you said hoping the courts
would rescue him from making an
independent judgement about the
constitutionality
but remember Jim Crow was majority rule
Jim Crow reflected local values and I
think local values and majority rule are
not all they're cracked up to be
this is a perfect example of where
individuals get oppressed by local
majorities right and the the basic idea
of federal government stepping in and
doing something about the enforcement of
particular rights that are specifically
defined I think is important I think
that the Civil Rights Act I tend to
agree with the argument that the Civil
Rights Act is is effectively what ended
segregation not the ruling in Brown
versus Board which I feel actually
didn't do very much desegregation didn't
actually accomplish anything via brown
person voting rights act right the
Voting Rights Act of a sudden black
people could vote and Strom Thurmond
said I hire a black person for my staff
I mean he immediately got the picture so
that's the power of the legislature not
the power of the of the power of the
judiciary and I guess the deployer that
struck me was you make a very strong
argument in favor of the ruling in
Lawrence vs Texas and against Justice
Scalia's dissent in Lawrence vs Texas
and you say well you know that the basic
notion of rights is a sort of John
Stuart Mill version of rights that I get
to wave my hand in the air so long
center hit you in the face so what
exactly does the government have to do
with regulating private bedroom
activities that's a principle with which
I fully agree I am Not sure it's a
principle with which the founders would
have fully agreed particularly since
many of them were in favor of laws that
regulated exactly that sort of behavior
right and I guess the question becomes
since we are not talking about the
morphing of rights beyond what the
founders suggested is there any limiting
principle there whatsoever I think there
is and I mean try and explain it with
reference to Scalia and another part of
the Constitution the Eighth Amendment
the Eighth Amendment prohibits cruel and
unusual punishment the Eighth Amendment
is why one reason why Scalia defined
himself as a faint-hearted originalist
while they were sitting in Philadelphia
in 1787 writing that and while in a few
years after that they were
ratifying the Eighth Amendment it was
common practice in America to crop ears
and brand cheeks floggings whippings
pillories etc none of which would we
tolerate now not Scalia went back and
forth he finally said late in his life
okay if a state legislature wanted to
flog
people they'd be stupid but
constitutional I think they're
unconstitutional here's how I think you
get there by being true to I think there
is such a thing as intention originalism
what was the intent of the authors and
ratifiers of the 8th amendment it was to
prevent cruelty as government policy now
that does not mean it meant to prevent
cruelty as it was understood in the
1790s it meant cruelty as society
understood as it evolves now Earl Warren
said there are evolving standards of
decency that marked the maturation of a
society and because Earl Warren said
that a lot of conservative believed that
let me say something about Earl Warren
before he was chief justice he was
governor of California before he was
governor he was Attorney General before
he was Attorney General he was a
district attorney and he knew what went
on in the back rooms of police stations
and a lot of the criminal justice
decisions of the war in court came from
hit that that the Chief Justice knew
what was going on and I think
conservatives ought to be able to
accommodate that intention originalism
says what were they intending when we
get to the brown decision school
segregation it would have been much
cleaner if instead of the Warren Court
going in did a lot of sociology if they
just said hey look we're guaranteed
equal protection of the laws this is
obviously unequal derivative would have
been cleaner people could have
understood it I think that that's true I
just hesitate to allow intention
originalism in any we wouldn't do it in
any other area of the law right if you
read the Sherman Antitrust Act you
wouldn't simply reinterpret it based on
the evolving standards of the meaning
words you would read it as literally as
possible right and if we want to change
the law we we have legislators we have
it which require effectively super
majorities given the filibuster we have
methods of changing the law and having
the Supreme Court step in and curtail a
lot of the debate that is
happening whether it's in the Oberlin or
even in cases where again I agree with
the outcome with Lawrence vs Texas it's
it seems to me a dangerous and not you
know you said we have to embrace the
danger but it seems to me the danger
from having unelected justices who are
unanswerable to any form of public
blowback make the rules as opposed to we
can get rid of certain people we can
replace them with other people that's
not I'm still very much in favor of the
checks and balances I just wonder if
there's no actual check or balance on
the judiciary well you cited in a moment
ago the great Alex pickle who was a
clerk for Felix Frankfurter and my
colleague and mentor in a way of bob
bork Alex pickles great books about the
least dangerous branch quoting Alexander
Hamilton courts have neither the purse
nor the sword how much damage can they
do well we know there are a lot of debts
and the exercise force or will then they
lose their legacy quite I'm saying that
again you're I concede everything you
say about the potential dangers there's
no safety in politics what do you fear
most I fear most majority rule majority
abuse of majorities so in your book you
talk a lot about sort of the secular
roots of the of the Republic and you you
kick back pretty strongly against the
notion that this is a judeo-christian
Republic or a Christian Republic
obviously I agree that there is nothing
in the Constitution that mandates a
particular religious viewpoint but I
feel like you may be giving some short
shrift to the judeo-christian roots of
some of the very ideas that you're
talking about so you say sort of that
secularism or agnosticism atheism that
these kick in favor of conservatism
maybe you can explicate that argument so
I don't know mischaracterizes know that
the chapter in the book that I had most
fun writing was called conservatism
without theism can I be autobiographical
from Oris my father's father was a
Lutheran minister and my father is a
young boy but sit outside pastor wills
study and listen to pastor will in some
of his congregants wrestling with the
problem of reconciling the doctrines of
free will and grace
that made my father a philosopher a lot
of religious personal philosophy and I
grew up in a secular household hostile
to religion I've described myself as an
amiable low voltage atheist I'm married
to a fierce presbyterian some that live
and let live I don't deny the enormous
contribution of judeo-christian thought
to the culture that produced eventually
and then 18th 19th centuries democracy I
say in my book that Martin Luther hollow
is autocratic as can be and a ferocious
opponent of peasant revolts and all the
rest nevertheless when he stood at the
diet of arms and said I cannot do
otherwise he's kinda Condors other than
be rebellion he that was asserting the
primacy of conscience the great
Protestant contribution to Western
civilization and the primacy of
conscience is the basis of individualism
the heart of the kind of conservatism
I'm talking about and the kind of
conservatism against which some
conservatives as you said a moment ago
are in rebellion against kind of what
they consider excessive individualism
what I wanted to argue here was there is
no not that there's any incompatibility
between religion and conservatism but
there's no necessity for a religious
basis of conservatism people say well
what about the founders the founders
basically that the most important one
were deists deism to me is barely a
religion religion should explain and
join and console all deism does is sort
of explain that everything's here
because God created it and then he left
someone said the deist God is like a
rich aunt in Australia benevolent but
rarely heard for I just you know I don't
I don't think deism counts as a religion
it seems to me that the Luke
in the world Lucretius sort of my model
here he said the world is all world one
of the Greek playwright said the phrase
world is king having driven out Zeus I'm
so good get rid of Zeus
I don't want gods interfering in our
lives world is just fine I'm back to the
conservative Sensibility God losing
control of events in the Bible and if
you embrace world and cosmology itself
all that we know about the great
crashing world of the universe suggests
that there is perfectly possible to have
design if you will things that look
created but weren't created by a creator
they just happened
I quote Huck Finn to that effect in the
chapter did on the raft with Jim and
they look up and they said was was they
created the Stars or do they just
happened I'm gonna just happen school so
there are a couple questions that spring
from them one is whether practically
speaking obviously can be conservative
than being atheist you can be a
conservative being us some people denied
that you know Whittaker Chambers said a
man without mysticism is a monster well
that since it made me a monster I kind
of resented Russell Kirk said that a
defining element of conservatism has to
be a religious sense I don't have it so
I don't like being read out of the
movement on religious grounds yes I
think it is perfectly possible just as
it's perfectly possible to you fully
moral and sometimes more than a
religious person atheist it's perfectly
possible to be a conservative while
being an atheist I don't know that
atheism tends toward conservatism in
fact I think that it tends toward the
opposite that could very well be
statistically speaking obviously as
Rochin declines in America so so has
conservatism the relationship between
religion and any doctrine is contingent
and there's no question that you're
right empirical aim as a matter of fact
religion tends to make people more
susceptible to conservatism and atheism
and I'm gonna make the slightly stronger
argument that even some of the premises
that you're basing conservatives on do
require a footing and religion so to
take the example of natural right
there's nothing in nature that dictates
natural right at all obviously the
nature is a place where things kill
other things and eat them
and so the idea of rights that spring
from that is actually quite unnatural I
mean nature is a creation of hierarchy
and power hierarchies and religion from
cloth exactly I mean this is why the
original interpretation of Darwinism for
the first seventy years of its existence
tended toward social Darwinism and
fascism was the idea that nature was
counted against rights and that it was
survival that actually mattered most and
so the notion of individual rights based
in natural rights that actually does not
spring from anything atheistic that
would be one contention the other
contention I'd make is that your
conservatism is very much dependent on
the notion that you are free actor
acting in a world that has certain
predictable rules to it that either
emerge from class or emerge from a
creator but even the notion of free will
the idea that we have the capacity to
choose is an assumption that you have to
make about the universe that is simply
not present in a scientific material
science right that's a great
philosophers joke of course I believe in
free will I have no choice hey the I
believe there is as the great
conservative James Q Wilson that
greatest social scientists of the last
50 years wrote a book called the moral
sense I believe there is a moral sense
how it evolved I don't know that there
it is I think it exists we are disposed
to compassion and kindness and promise
keeping in other ways I say in the book
that in fact I think we are at the end
of the day rule utilitarians that is the
greatest happiness for the greatest
number is produced over time by obeying
certain rules and that the rules include
respecting certain rights that we
empirically from historical experience
have decided are crucial to human
flourishing and I think those
individualism is crucial to human
flourishing
thank individual property rights are
absolutely crucial to human flourishing
because property creates a zone of
sovereignty in which you can operate
none of that requires a grounding and
other than observation anthropology
sociology and history it does not
require a theology I mean that that is
isn't that sort of linking is an art in
a way that that is logically
inappropriate meaning that because
things have been that way
thus it is a moral rule as opposed to an
actual principled moral rule that there
are natural rights that these do exist
that they pre-exists government in other
words the the problem with rule
utilitarianism is that a lot of things
are utilitarian that would conflict with
your individual rights based morality
rule not I think I don't think they
would conflict over time that's why it's
it's not act utilitarianism it's rule
utilitarianism that you judge not just
individual acts but a pattern of
behavior a series of social arrangements
we know that democracy is pretty good we
know that without property people do not
flourish because there is no there are
no means for asserting themselves and
exercising sovereignty and making
choices which are the essence of freedom
so again it's dangerous I can't anchor
this in some cosmology I mean I guess
then and that I guess is the problems
that when you read the Declaration of
Independence it is not a rule
utilitarian document it is it is a
document of essential principle about
the way things should be not saying that
in the past rights have worked and
therefore rights are good but well there
the author of the Declaration said that
these truths are self-evident by which
he meant and those who agreed with him
been evident to Minds not not clouded by
ignorance or superstition they did not
mean that everyone on the planet
accepted these propositions damn few did
or still do for that matter but I think
Jefferson was right Minds unclouded by
ignorance and superstition clear minds
clear thinking minds accept those truths
as self-evident so let's talk about the
the question of the role of government
in light of sort of a rule utilitarian
viewpoint so folks on the political left
would suggest that in a in a rule
utilitarian way the government should be
involved in for example health care
because when the government is involved
in health care then there is a
universality that applies to health care
even if the price is higher or even if
it means that certain people on the
upper end don't get the health care that
they need in the upper end of the both
the money spectrum and the age spectrum
then that is the way that it ought to be
how do you apply a small government
conservatism to questions of where the
government should be involved in
American life the first question is the
proper scope and actual competence of
government can government do what people
want it to do does it know how or is it
to use Hayek's great phrase the fatal
conceit of government that it can
acquire information and manipulate
information and act disinterested lian
information better than markets can
allocate information and generate it as
all markets are information generating
devices governments first of all don't
act disinterested me I wish my
progressive friends would sit down while
the James Buchanan's works Nobel Prize
winner from the University of Virginia
who gave us the public choice theory
which is that governments are run by
human beings and the private sector
human beings try to maximize profits
basically broadly understood in
government human beings try to maximize
power government is not disinterested
government is a political actor
government is a faction government is
blues morons has half a grip on a point
she says look at the government it is no
accident she says since she's right that
five of the ten richest counties on a
per-capita basis are in the Washington
area trillions of dollars sloshing
through Washington she's right that the
government is often the plaything of
factions that are intense compact
articulate
confident in a well lawyer they
manipulate the government they can
understand the more affluent and
educated can understand the gears and
pulleys and levers of this opaque
machine this great Leviathan named
Washington then however Elizabeth Warren
another progresses say solutions to make
the government much bigger and much more
powerful get it much more deeply
involved in allocating wealth and
opportunity at which place it don't know
why please you've just described the
government as given to certain
pathologies that are inherent in a large
government that is deeply involved in
the allocation of wealth and opportunity
want to reduce the amount of the role of
money in politics reduce the role of
politics and money see what happens
that's why I say progressives have a
firm grip on half a point lost so in a
system based on on utilitarian
evaluation over time what is the
prospect for change so folks on the Left
would say well this doesn't allow for
change
nearly quickly enough because it sort of
forecloses grand experiments it suggests
that stuff that is working half well
maybe there is a better way and we just
haven't tried it yet and on the
conservative side there people say well
rule utilitarianism because it's not
rooted in a fundamental unchanging
principle or say that that actually does
allow for exactly that sort of
experimentation that can get quite
dangerous because you don't know it's
failed until it's failed whatever
progresses criticize about capitalism
surely they can't say it doesn't produce
change I mean the greatest change in the
history of human race occurred from the
late eighteenth century to today called
the great enrichment by Deirdre
McCloskey and her three volumes book on
the bourgeois virtues capitalism is a
permanent revolution Marx writing the
greatest him to capitalism in the
Communist Manifesto said under
capitalism everything's solid disappears
into air he's right it he said he
understood capitalism most revolutionary
thing that ever happened he just didn't
like the destination but capitalism is a
constant it's a permanent revolution but
strata
trotsky's right saying you know and
Trotsky should have been a capitalist
but capitalism is the permanent
revolution and government the more
complicated society gets said the
progressives said Woodrow Wilson the
more complicated it gets the more
acquires government to manage it exactly
wrong more complicated society gets the
more there is the government doesn't
understand the more there is to know the
more information there is out there that
government can not possibly master and
apply to society so get out of the way
hey where we are in the country right
now you mentioned Marx and his belief
that the end goal the end points of this
particular journey is not the right end
point there is one thing in America to
argue about the means to get to the end
point it's another thing to argue about
the end point itself do you think that
we've reached beyond these sort of
conciliatory tested over time religion
Tillet arianism you're talking about
when we don't even agree on what the end
point should look like I don't think we
should agree on end points I don't think
we should anticipate the end we don't
know what the end is gonna be never give
it tiny just a simple example until 2007
millions and millions of Americans had
cell phones and were happy then in 2008
along came a smartphone and everyone
hated the cell phones they had good
creative dissatisfaction so we have
these little devices everyone I have
more computing power in my pocket than
NATO had in 1960 I mean I have more
access to information than the Library
of Alexandria or the Library of Congress
for that back wonderful is that the end
I doubt it someone's going to come along
and make me extremely dissatisfied with
my iPhone whatever it is it is its
custom end goals not just yeah and pry
okay well friends what you mean by goals
the great moment in modernity was when
first began sort of with Machiavelli but
then Hobbes and Locke and others and
said you know people are
disagree about the ultimate good they
just are sorry what we have to do is
figure out institutional arrangements so
that people who disagree about
fundamentals can still live together
that's called modernity it's called
modern society it's why a number of
religious conservatives don't like
modernity and are quite candid about it
there's been a lot of candor in the
world some of these conservatives today
say we don't like modernity good I
admire their forthrightness Woodrow
Wilson said I don't like the founders
Woodrow Wilson said do not read the
first two paragraphs of the Declaration
it's fourth-of-july fluff don't like the
separation about that windrow Wilson I
can exhaust you in the day with all his
defects but can do he had and I admired
that so in one second I'm finally going
to ask you about the topic we have now
avoided for a full hour and that of
course is President Trump and your
thoughts on President Trump but if you
want to hear george will's thoughts on
President Trump you actually have to
subscribe over at daily where you have
to pay us to subscribe go over to daily
wire com click subscribe you can hear
the end of our conversation there plus
someone asking about baseball too
because we can't end on that note
George will thank you so much for
stopping by it really is an honor and a
pleasure to have you thank you for your
time spread from I enjoyed it thank you
very much
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy borin associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Caitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Camino hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20